et trottoirs 11 bat au palais royal
belge est outillé
[Musique]
senlis un matin d'août présents et
passés se côtoient
marcel bluwal tourner dans ses vieilles
rues comme tout cinéaste en quête
d'authenticité
la suite des aventures de vidocq
l'ancien bagnard devenu cette fois ci
pour six épisodes d'une heure directeur
de la sûreté
claude brasseur remplaçant bernard noël
marque lully cours danièle lebrun
j'accélère cent quarante comédiens et
figurants prendre à senlis ses
apparences de cité du 19e siècle
mais sur la forme les années à huy les
menottes
les menaces d ce plan là allez attention
révélations et il arrête tu passes ton
mouvement des changes n'arrête pas
tomber je verrai s'il vous plaît matière
vide avec 5,61 de deuxième tout le moins
comme si avec ça tu t'habilles connais
[Applaudissements]
certains noms des produits renchérit un
peu de retard quelqu'un se met à la
bourre mais on en tient une bonne place
à la tête
maeder on s'était non plus de 500 bien
de quelle meilleure saveur vanille pour
quick les deux merci d'apprécier non
lieu et bah c'est un feuilleton
typiquement français pour la bonne et
simple raison que c'est un personnage
essentiellement français et qui se
déroule dans un cadre français et dans
une commande ya dans un style de comics
qui rejoint un petit peu celui des pieds
nickelés volontairement or l'équilibré
et elle te coûter un petit peu
anarchiste un petit peu surréaliste
c'est très typique man français
cela dit c'est aussi des costumes mais
ça ça semble être typiquement français
parce que l'étranger il ya beaucoup
renoncent et il semble que ça plaît en
france la question mais c'était près du
pont tout d'abord parce que sa banque
marcel et cela au moins pour un amour
voilà tricher on va la chercher
[Applaudissements]
une école
c'est improvisé parce que vous faites ça
commence à me réveille enfin sur des
personnages toujours moi puisque je fais
pas facile j'ai une idée de ce que j'ai
envie de faire mais ça dépend du dieu ça
dépend je propose des coupeuses bon
d'avoir un pistolet jamais même je sais
pas je dis n'importe quoi donjons les
maillots que j'ai fait je m'étais coupé
faut que ça ait l'air organisés une fois
qu'on monte tout ça mais ils comptent
autour dans l'extérieur ou est repris
mais mon studio davout être à même de
changer le progrès de notre photo
maintenant c'est à moi c'est beaucoup
plus général au feuilleton que dans une
une émission dramatique coincé le long
métrage ordinaire je veux dire que on
découpe encore beaucoup de chose qu'est
ce qui m'arrive c'est viviane on peut
presque considérer que cécile film d'une
heure enfin si c'est ça c'est l'un des
noms comme mais j'ai demandé enfin nous
sommes convenus l'auteur de kill your
hands 7h au moins la matière
je n'aurais monnaie c'est à dire que le
style on a été beaucoup plus serré que
celui d'un film de long métrage ça
rejoint le style des 26 minutes parce
que la matière
inclus dans le film d'une heure est très
très volumineuse et qu'il faut serrer
pour tenir en mars qui fait des
donations harry cleven ce qu'un film
nommé par armand google derrière si vous
voulez j'ai tout dessiné ben non mais
c'est je préfère toujours quand ça se
déclenche seuls juges alors y est
d'abord une réaction de violence trenet
quoi et puis attention
élevez vous vite et disons que
moralement ou cacher le venger les
romains mais c'est tout juste la mise en
avant sur prêts à aller
[Rires]
comme j'aime assez j'aurais vous le
disais ce qui est spécifique et le
tournage d'un feuilleton la rapidité
france elles sont seules à vendre à sa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
succession de séquences développement
des séquences très synthétique alors ça
donne sur le temps du tournage on se
déplace quatre fois par jour
la fois les ailleurs et ça donne une
espèce de rythme assez haletant et qu'il
est nécessaire pour le téléspectateur
parce que pour retenir son attention
faut être beaucoup plus violent
le feuilleton lui la belle longueur
poudrier c'est mieux d'avoir rassemblé
une équipe réduite fait d'avoir ou non
je veux dire la vérité il fallait
retourner on discutait avec un directeur
de la photo américain d'hollywood qui
fait des séries comme nous lui au lieu
d'avoir promis ni sinon à 9
le feuilleton avez-vous fait ou dit 3
358 558 les dernières années mais quelle
différence faites-vous avec des
défections comme cela on se donne 60 de
temps qu'à vous bon ça va plus vite ce
qui était abominable dans les tournages
c'est que le temps utile de tournage
réel mais bien sûr cette heure et demie
voire deux heures entre le fait
d'installer la caméra d'éclairer le
décor d'éclairer les personnages qu'est
ce qu'il me reste à melzer alors au
cinéma on tourne plus lentement et on
prend plus de temps et on prend plus de
temps le tournage est taillé bon nous il
faut faire comme si alors de vous
expliquer ce qu'on va faire et c'est les
plantes nous allons faire ensemble sans
comédiens et s'il veut jouer à la guerre
donc bagarre de rue il me faut des
flingues
je crois qu'il faut payer de mots
feuilleton faut qu'il faut employer le
mot le mot télévision je pense que la
télévision va de plus en plus aux frais
de pareils aux comédiens et ils peuvent
feuilleton profite au feuilleton
dramatique que c'était affreux n'importe
quoi à l'extrême rigueur et puis hier à
des comédiens
cinéma une terre tu viens à des fois
qu'ils s'accordent pas très bien des
deux
à mon avis en principe on devrait faire
un comédien devrait pouvoir faire les
deux il y en a qui justement ça colle ça
colle à l'insa colpaert à l'eau soit
appuyé d'utilisation une chance de jouer
de manière
dans un rayon dure très longtemps
pendant la télé c'est de voir un
comédien pendant très longtemps c'est
forcément sur quoique du don même avant
la même avant même avant la guerre je
veux dire les cimes prenons voit
maintenant essayer ma taille s'aperçoit
que il y avait des emplois qui étaient
tenues toujours par les mêmes sans rien
il y avait des ferries qu'est-ce que
j'ai c'est de la rigolade en fait c'est
ça et ici et c'est un rigolo écart est
c'est un rigolo et puis l'autre c'était
un dramatique et puis l'autre c'était un
troisième couteau puisse appuyer la
catalogne ça existait déjà depuis les
gens pour pour ce qu'il représente comme
apparemment surtout attention là
pourquoi il ya un côté péjoratif à quoi
dans le feuilleton ben moi je suis
violemment contre il ya des aléas quinze
ans que je fais du feuilleton de temps
en temps entre les dramatiques ou les
films que je fais je trouve que c'est
une distance absolument merveilleux ce
qu'elle avait à faire
une question de jouer non en fait il n'y
a pas de raison que la télévision qui
est le moyen de contact que le spectacle
avec les gens maintenant beaucoup plus
que le cinéma ou théâtre ne parle pas
des événements contemporains sous forme
de feuilleton ça c'est pas encore ça
respire bien le faire un jour je crois
que le feuilleton avancera ce afin de
mieux en mieux de plus en plus fort
mais j'y crois pas et on peut faire
prendre conscience aux gens qu'un
certain nombre de problèmes de leur
époque par le fait que oui mais pas avec
un côté didactique on les envoie là le
problème on traite le problème
par le biais de la fiction et l'histoire
qui pour moi est quelque chose de très
démonstratif presque plus démonstratif
que l'émission dit d'actifs on traite le
problème de signe de sagesse qui est une
forme de spectacle aussi intelligent que
j'ai pratiqué personnellement pas aussi
je trouve que l'autre version pour moi
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
rohrer moteur silence oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]